[Music]
hello everyone i'm very pleased to
talk today with dr richard tremblay
emeritus professor of pediatrics and
psychology at the university of montreal
and emeritus professor of public health
at university college dublin in ireland
i've known richard for a long time since
the
mid 80s i worked with him in montreal
for a number of years along with my
supervisor
robert peel i i worked on alcoholism and
aggression at that time mostly and i i
did get to know richard quite well he
was a pronounced influence on my
on my scientific thinking especially in
relationship to subjects like
childhood aggression
adult antisocial behavior and
criminality and alcohol and drug abuse
and
richard
dominated i would say that
the social science research world in
quebec for 30 years uh
attracting a massively disproportionate
share of research funding because of the
quality of his
longitudinal studies those are long-term
studies following people over decades
very very clinical studies very very
very difficult to administer and to
design and to implement and to fund and
to write up and to analyze extremely
complicate complex work and i think you
can make a reasonable case that
well his work on aggression is
certainly among the most profound and
and unexpected of the last 50 years
in montreal he conducted elsewhere he
conducted a program of
both longitudinal and experimental
studies on physical cognitive emotional
and social development from conception
to adulthood although his main focus is
on the development and the prevention of
chronic physical aggression so that goes
in some sense to the heart of
criminology
he's an officer of the order of canada
which is roughly equivalent to a
canadian knighthood a fellow of the
royal society of canada and of the
academy of experimental criminology in
2017 he won the stockholm prize in
criminology for his research on the
developmental developmental origins of
violent behavior and i was hoping to
talk to richard today particularly
because the issue of aggression and more
specifically male aggression
is
uh extraordinarily
popular let's say a popular media topic
but the level of general uh
knowledge about
the scientific
about scientific research into
aggression and the conclusions of that
research is not disseminated well at all
and people are un unreasonably
misinformed about
what aggression is and how it emerges
and how it might be controlled and
and how it manifests itself in families
and what the implications of that are
for social policy and all of those
things and so i'm hoping today with
richard that we can
shed some light on all of this and
that's the purpose of the discussion so
i'm going to start by talking about some
of the topics addressed in the 1999
scientific paper that richard authored
along with a sequence of co-authors
called the search
for the age of
onset of physical aggression rousseau
a philosopher who assumed that people
were naturally good but corrupted by the
social order and bandura who
championed the idea of social learning a
psychologist
revisited rousseau and bandura revisited
richard starts by
pointing out that studies of aggression
often
fail to
separate physical aggression
from verbal aggression indirect
aggression microaggressions let's say
relational aggression opposition
competition and other so-called
externalizing behaviors so
maybe you could start by commenting up
about
on that richard because one of the key
features of your work is the specificity
of your definitions and
we need to know about the reason for
that
yes well
when i started
uh
doing research i i was doing research on
um juvenile delinquency essentially uh
the
the general problem of juvenile
delinquency i did my
phd thesis on this
and
i was brought
on to
study physical aggression because it
it appeared to be a
narrower
type of problem
um
easier to study than
simply
juvenile delinquency
and as i worked on that problem of of
aggression i realized
that people were
using the word aggression to mean all
sorts of things
and i sort of slowly
zoomed in on the physical aggression
research thinking that it would be much
simpler to study
and i did that
in part because i was interested
in looking at
the early signs of
problems with physical aggression
and when you start looking at
young children very young children
you become amazed to see
how frequently they
physically aggress each other
and they are
much less sophisticated than
elementary schools children or
adolescents or adults
so the action is really
on
into physical aggression and
as we measured the physical aggression
in early childhood and
developmentally over time
it became very obvious
that
what we were all thinking that
aggression
increased with age
and sort of peaked
in
adolescence late at lessons
we
showed
that physical regression was at its peak
in terms of frequency
around age between age two and age three
um
we
were looking at
in day care centers
and i i finally discovered
that the
place in the world where you're most at
risk
of being physically aggressed
is in a daycare center
when you're between age two and age
the amount of physical aggressions
is incredible
of course
they are not well coordinated and they
are not very strong so the damage
is not the same damage as
a physical fight when
you look at adolescence
but the frequency of physical aggression
is clearly there
and to a certain extent it
changed
my
way of looking
at this problem of aggression
to throughout development from very
early
childhood um until uh
until adulthood
okay so you you adopted a narrow focus
to begin with and you concentrated on
physical aggression and if i remember
correctly and please do correct me
the markers were so the even more basic
markers and measurable markers were
kicks hits bites and steels is that
correct yes exactly okay okay so now one
of the problems that scientific
researchers in the field of psychology
have is that
they try to investigate
uh terms that people often use
descriptively like anxiety
but a scientific category needs to be
only what it is and nothing else and so
it has to be it's a particular kind of
category if you say anxiety to someone
you usually surround that with an
explanatory framework so that the person
can understand what you're talking about
so you don't have to be that precise in
your use of the word anxiety but if
you're trying to measure it in a
repeatable way then you have to zero in
on something that is essentially as
close to one thing as you can manage and
it's narrow and you picked kicks hits
fights and steals and
i
i would say that is observable but it's
it also i think and probably not by
accident gets to the heart of what
people are really concerned about when
they talk about male criminality and
aggression because
the the biggest socio-cultural and
personal impact of criminal behavior or
maybe the most emotionally valid part of
it is the physical violence aspect and
that seems central is that fair yes yes
it is it's uh
uh whether it's war or uh being uh
physically aggressed by a neighbor
it's
it
it creates more damage and it's a threat
to your life
yes so okay so it's you so it's useful
to simple it was useful to simplify it
so that it could be measured and
observed but it was also a move that
allowed you to get right to the heart of
what was important about antisocial
behavior and criminal behavior and so
forth
and and okay okay so
and then you
it's so easy to jump over these things
and even in your papers because
these ideas are revolutionary in a sense
that isn't immediate
immediately obvious in the cautious
manner in which they're couched because
people do assume for example that
children learn aggression and that and
as you pointed out that aggression is
much more common to say among adolescent
males or young adult males but
even much to your surprise
that isn't what you found so i would
like to ask you two questions about that
like
why do you think you were surprised what
had you gone in there expecting and how
does this violate the assumptions that
people including scientists generally
make about aggression yeah
well it um you you cited the
russo and bandura
the research on aggression
made me realize
that their perspective on we are
born good
and it's your environment that makes you
bad
didn't work
when you were looking at one of the
worst things you call bad is
physical aggression
because we were following children uh
from essentially birth
and the children that we
we were following them they're now in
their 40s and we are still
following them
we
we showed
that
between
birth
and adulthood
the time at which you use physical
aggression against others most often
is
between
two and three and the reason it's not at
one or or
at six months it's because by the time
you're two and three
you're
much more able
to address
others in terms of you you can run you
can hit you can kick well as you don't
see that at six months
but these behaviors are are clearly
there
at the start
and
as we followed the children over time
up to adulthood
we saw very clearly
that the frequency of physical
aggression was
going on was
dropping there was less and less
frequency of physical aggressions
up
to
adulthood
um so the idea that we
learn
from and then for our environment to
address
doesn't fit the data at all
it's rather
with time
we learn not to physically aggress
because everybody
even those who were physically
addressing very
often with time
the frequency decreases
there is
there is more damage
if you get hit by an adolescence than by
a two-year-old
but in terms of frequency
we
learn
not to use physical aggression as we get
older
okay so what we might say that this
constitutes a delayed victory for the
philosopher thomas hobbes who exactly
and from um
the
the inventor
of uh the
original sin
the idea of the original sin
comes from
the
the saint
uh what's his name
he he lived he lived in um
[Music]
in rome
um
this this saint
describes
he says
i want to find when
i started to
commit
sins
and he says i went to see the children
very young children and i can see that i
started to sin
very early in life
i beat my parents i hit everybody
and so this idea has been there for a
long time but there has been this big
resistance
to believe
that we are born to live like animals
and that with time
we learn to live in a civil society
okay so do you have any sense richard of
why that resistance
manifested itself and and but and i
would also say continues to because it
seems to me that
the default view that people are good
especially children innately and that
they're corrupted by exposure to bad
models and by society i would say that's
that's the default view and it's
certainly the default view on the left
end of the political spectrum
so why do you think that that became so
dominant if the data
even the observational data was there
thousands of years ago let's say and and
and certainly is there in the scientific
literature now yes well um
i guess it's a it's a
normal reaction of humans to
not
to accept
the the
from an evolutionary perspective we are
animals that have
sort of
learned to live together
in a
more sophisticated way than than
the monkeys
and the chimpanzees but it's very clear
that if if we take a darwinian
perspective
to evolution
um it makes a lot of sense and
darwin was also one of those who
who started who said at one point
i am looking at the way my children
behave
and
it's clear that my children are using
physical aggression
within the first year of life
um
yeah he was a very careful observer he
was
and it's
he wrote
quite a lot about
the behavior of his children and it
inspired him
in terms of understanding
uh human
human development okay so back to back
to hobbes he's sort of the antithesis of
russo and hobbes believed that in the
state of nature life would be nasty
brutish and short and that it was only
socialization that made us civilized and
your data essentially support that
viewpoint except it's it's more complex
because rousseau wins to some degree
because you've tracked out three
developmental pathways
so
although
on average young children are more
aggressive than older children and
adolescents if you look your your
research and others indicates that if
you look at the population of young
children all children are not equally
violent
and so maybe you could walk us through
that yes um
yes there are
important differences between children
those who are
most
aggressive
use physical aggression most often
early
in life
are
i don't have the data in front of me but
it it's
not much more than
20 25
and a lot of children are not using
physical aggression and there is the uh
difference between males and and females
we get
similar developmental trajectories
but essentially most girls do not use uh
physical aggression
okay so your data the data i reviewed
this morning
suggested that about 30 of children use
very little aggression to begin with 50
use some and about 17 percent are quite
aggressive and they stay that way they
tend to stay that way
they they remain
relatively eye to the others but they
they decrease with time
right frequency decreases with time so
right so so
those who are likely to be aggressive in
adolescence were also likely to be
aggressive as children but all children
including the aggressive children tend
towards less aggression as they mature
yes yes but also again again we should
it's it's useful to repeat this so 30
percent are show very little aggression
across the board right from childhood
onward
50 are in the mixed group using
aggression sometimes when they're
children but that declines precipitously
as they age and then there's 17 percent
they decline as well but the population
of aggressive adolescents is
disproportionately drawn
from those children who were
exceptionally aggressive
in their earliest infancy
yes
okay and they're okay so then let's
focus on the ones that were particularly
aggressive so rousseau wins a bit
because there's a substantial proportion
of children who just don't use
aggression at all as a as a strategy so
it's a mixed it's a mixed model
and and so
um
the the peop that the the the aggressive
individuals
the biggest risk factor i think you
identified for
being in the more aggressive category
the most aggressive category was gender
sex
so if you're a boy it's much more
probable and i think the odds were two
to one is is that correct approximately
that uh
i i don't remember exactly but if you if
you've looked at it this morning you
must be closer
close to uh
yeah and then you showed okay so so it
was it was um
they were they were more likely to be
male
and then there were other
important contributors as well they were
more likely for example to have mothers
who did not complete their high school
education
that was the next
that the next most important risk factor
what what other risk factors for that
early aggression did you identify
well
um in
most of the studies we we are showing
that
uh
a lot of the characteristics of the
of the
boys who have problems are
characteristics related to their mothers
having
problems um
both psychological uh
and
[Music]
social
social problems
and i've i've called that the
hydra
problem in the sense that um
girls
who have
adjustment problems
are
likely to have
children
and especially boys who will have
important problems
and what do you mean by adjustment
problems if if you're going to
characterize what you've observed about
the mothers who are more likely to
have aggressive boys in particular and
also to not
control it as well as they develop yeah
how would you describe the typical
[__] girl or this
girls who who fail in school
um
uh girls who um
[Music]
have
emotional problems
um
girls
in
all everything that we've measured
for example in terms of problems with
smoking with drugs
um
almost
every
problem that you can mention
there is a tendency
for
girls who have these problems
to
have children
and especially boys
who will have difficulty it's not only
difficulties with physical aggression
but
their children will
have more problems in social adjustment
in
in um succeeding in school
um
and so
over time
it's been it's become quite clear to me
that
if we want to help
children in terms of their development
and high-risk children
the best strategy
is to support
to give support to girls
early on
who have
adjustment problems
in
in the school system
because
they are the best predictors of boys who
will have the problems that we are
talking about
so there is this intergenerational
problem
girls are more involved in helping
their children
grow up than males
but also it's related to
what's happening during pregnancy so if
you have a girl
who during pregnancy is smoking taking
drugs
using alcohol
it's quite clear from simply a
medical
biological
perspective
uh that
this
child's brain will be affected in a
negative way
and
that child will have much more
difficulty
controlling
himself
and
that's
quite clear it's relatively clear that
the boys will suffer
from that perspective more than
than the baby girls
but the baby girls will
reproduce um
the same type of problems that their
mother had
so then so that hypothetically then the
aggression problem among among the boys
will occur among the daughters of the
girls you're talking about a generation
later
um
you said it's it's transmitted
intergenerationally so
yeah girls that you're talking about
have girls and they don't do well either
even though it's not to manifest in
aggression but maybe their children are
also at risk that's right and that's the
multi-generational aspect yeah okay so
pregnancy is occur is crucial
and
and you talked about some of the
behaviors that can compromise fetal
development and of those behaviors
is there a rank order of catastrophe so
for example i fetal alcohol alcohol is
extremely toxic during pregnancy
particularly at certain key moments
there's a period when the hippocampus
develops if i remember correctly and if
you drink on that day or that week then
that's likely to produce long-standing
cognitive problems so there are critical
periods alcohol use during pregnancy
smoking are those the major risk factors
for for for pregnancy trouble or or
what else what other factors well
there's there's also
some mental health problems in terms of
for example depression
we haven't measured everything
but
most of the
emotional behavioral
problems that individuals have
are likely to
affect
the next generation
and
because mothers are the ones who are
[Music]
getting pregnant
what they do during pregnancy is going
to affect
the development of their child's brain
and that will affect how well
they
adjust to their environment
after
so you do you think that whatever
neurological impairment emerges as a
consequence of
less than optimal pregnancy
increases the proclivity for aggression
per se or decreases the probability that
the child will be able to learn to
control it
is there any data on that
no it's a hard distinction to me no it's
it's a very hard distinction um
no there's not
clear data on that i i think the
the approach to
to getting
closer to
understanding exactly what's happening
is when we are using a
prevention
approach an experiment in terms of
prevention and it's maybe it's
it's time to introduce this approach
part of the logi the studies that i've
been doing are longitudinal studies
where we
simply follow
thousands of families from
pregnancy until
the the children's
adult life
but a
a more
uh
interesting approach is
but more difficult is experimental
interventions so
in those experimental interventions
researchers
think up of a way of treating the
problem of preventing the problem
and so we do an experiment and there
have been very nice experiments that
have been done
on helping
young women who have
behavior problems emotional problems and
become pregnant in helping them
supporting them during pregnancy
and after birth
so that
we can see to what extent we can help
their children adjust better to
their environment
and
david olds in the united states has been
doing what i think are the best studies
on
the experimental studies on helping
high-risk
girls
and the results he's been doing this for
at least um
25 quarter of a century
and so we have data on the outcome the
long-term outcome for the children
and it's very clear that
giving support to
young pregnant women who have
behavior mental health problems
is
helping their children in the long run
to adjust much better to their
environment
and interestingly the latest data that
i've seen
is showing that it's helping
the baby girls more than helping
the baby boys so it may take at least
two
two generations
to be
able to help the boys
um
that would have major problems if their
mothers were not being helped
so
what is it that what does the support
that's offered to these mothers that
works
consist of what needs what needs to be
done and you also mentioned young women
so is one of the risk factors as well
age of mother at birth
yes well yes
age of mother at birth it has
traditionally
been um
an indicator that there is a problem
with
girls what about what about marital
status i mean there's a huge body of
literature and again correct me if if
i'm not up to date on this indicating
that
on average
children without fathers
stable fathers do much worse across a
whole variety of indices than children
with stable fathers and now you could
make a couple of cases for that you
could say that
maybe the women that you're talking
about
are less likely to attract a stable
partner and so it isn't actually the
presence of the man that's the
determining factor it's the fact that
instability is more likely in a
relationship if the young mother is
unstable herself
um
what do you think about and you're not
seeing a role for fathers precisely in
in the developmental trajectory of
aggression so what do you what do you
how do you
comprehend the fatherlessness literature
and the literature you're discussing how
do they fit together or not
um well uh part of the problem is
of mating
and there's very interesting
data coming out from
i think it's in sweden
at least one of the
scandinavian scandinavian countries
where
it's very clear
because they have access to the
data from the whole population
the data is pretty good
and there's clearly um
assortative mating
among
people who have psychological problems
so you have to define that you'll have
to define that first okay
what's the phenomenon assortative mating
means that
you
are mating with
a mate that has some of
the same characteristics as you have so
if if we are
talking say for mental illness
if girls who who have mental
illness problems
are more likely to
have children with men who have mental
illness problems
um
so do you suppose that's a consequence
of access across hierarchies so
anyway if you're if you're put into a
socio economic rung in part because of
your
impaired mental ability let's say uh
either cognitively or with regards to
mental disorder that the people that
you're exposed to and likely to initiate
a relationship are much more likely to
be drawn from that strata
yes well the yeah there is uh there's
assortative mating related to
um
the the social class that you are in so
you people tend to mate with
people from
the same social class but within a
social class
there appears to be uh also assertive
mating for
having problems and
to a certain extent it makes sense that
that
if
if you're
not
if you're mentally you have mental
health problems you are not attractive
to someone
who doesn't have
problems
so people
who don't have mental health problems
tend to mate with
people who don't have mental thought
problems and those who have mental
health problems tend to mate with i mean
this is not
uh
we're talking about probabilities here
right right right so so so it becomes
very difficult to parse apart the
biological influences and the influences
of impaired physical health and the
sociological and family environment
influences
yes what do you see as a what do you see
as the role of of as the beneficial or
harmful role of
fathers in uh in a
in in the upbringing of children in
relationship to violence
well um
there is uh certainly um
the
the model in the sense that if uh
if
the parents uh the
father or the mother are
using physical aggression with the
children and are using physical
aggression among themselves
it's very hard for a child to learn
not to use physical aggression so that
there is
a moderate
well it's so is it is it modeling of the
aggression or is it failure to model the
inhibition of aggression which seems
well it seems in some sense more likely
it's because
the thing about aggression especially at
the level that you study is it's not
that sophisticated in some sense it's
not that hard to learn to hit it's sort
of there what's hard to learn is to
implement this like if you want
someone's toy you want to play with
their toy and you're little
you can hit them and take it or you can
figure out a more sophisticated strategy
so that you can both play together but
that's actually hard and that in
principle would take modeling and proper
reinforcement and all of that and and so
part of this i think is a model of
simplicity versus sophistication yes and
and then we talked about this years ago
too and i'd like to know how your
thoughts have stayed the same or changed
over time
do you think that the children who are
becoming that that children as they
become less aggressive are inhibiting
their aggression or do you think they're
integrating it into
more sophisticated behaviors
well and
yeah
i think it's it's both
um
it's both in in the sense that from a a
cognitive perspective um
as we
develop uh we are we become cognitively
more sophisticated and we
understand the consequences of these
uh behaviors if
if you hit and you get hit and
with time you learn that
you it's you won't
get hit as often if you if you're not
hitting
um
so um
and there is that
control over yourself um
and
there are the models so
i i don't think it's one or the other
it's a number of factors that
bring you
to
uh understand
and to
be able to control your behavior
and not use aggression
um
and use more more sophisticated ways
when you see
um
parents who have been successful in
bringing their more aggressive child's
aggression under control developmentally
have you developed any insight into the
nature of the disciplinary strategies
they're using because i was looking at
at the outcome studies the intervention
outcome studies today before we talked
and i thought
um
what happens in families that are
functioning well when a child manifests
an aggressive behavior what sort of
disciplinary strategies are implemented
to encourage that child let's say to use
his words
instead of heading or something like
that and again in my observations of
parents who don't know what they're
doing with their children they're often
left completely adrift when their child
manifests in aggressive behavior they
seem to have absolutely no idea about
how to respond to that in a way that
makes it less likely in the future or
sometimes they even covertly reinforce
it
so have you are the micro analysis of
disciplinary strategies there yet or or
is it still vague and unknown
well
there are there are efforts at
looking at that but
from from my perspective
this area
this is so complex
there are so many
factors
that are involved
that it's very hard to dissect
um
in in the way that would be satisfying
to answer the the questions that
the the that you are
asking
let's
come back to the
experimental interventions the
experimental interventions with
pregnant women
who appear to be at risk
because they have
behavior problems they have mental
health problems
the
work that david the old says was doing
the interventions last
from
early pregnancy until the child's
second year of life
it's it visits its home visitation
by nurses
and
these interventions
with
these women
have
you look 20 years down the line
and their girls are
adapting much better than the control
group girls
that didn't get this two years of
intervention
so
what we can see from these
experiments
is that it's possible
to change the life
of the children of these girls that had
adjustment problems
but getting at
exactly what
was done
within um
these two years
there is a general
push towards
let's do everything we can
right to help them
and it's clear that it it works there is
something
it doesn't
tell us the my new details of uh what
happened in the brain of the child or
during pregnancy it's it's telling us
these interventions
will save us money and will help
part of
uh individuals who have problems in in
the long run um and so what do the
interventions consist of so what would a
what would a girl who was a pregnant
girl who who was enrolled in one of
these programs
expect what would she receive as a
consequence of of the intervention well
she will receive from the nurse
visits
at home and
the nurse will
consult her
into everything that she has to decide
in terms of the quality of what she eats
during pregnancy and
in the interaction she has with other
people everything
that's uh
difficult for them
she can share with the nurse and the
nurse will help
solve
the problem well it sounds it sounds
like the provision of a of a grandmother
well
grandmother in some sense
a mother yeah it's it's uh
it's it's not like a psychotherapy where
you you follow
um
exactly
uh the way the person is thinking it's
it's more of a
and and these nurses with time learn to
deal with with these different
with these different problems
there there is
another approach
and
which
could be done at the same time as
the nurse home visitation program i
think
that stopping at age two
is too early
and i've
i've been pushing for
um
[Music]
getting
um
another type of intervention at least
from age two because we know
that age two is uh
the time when
um the children have
physical aggression the more
for physical aggression they have
their problems are
at the top
at age two um and so the other approach
that
could be a good compliment
is
daycare quality daycare
and the experiments that have been done
with daycare quality daycare
are showing very long-term effects also
on
the children
i think the
the best approach that has not been
tried yet
is
to use them to use the nurse home
visitation
jointly
with
the daycare
quality daycare interventions
the quality daycare interventions have
shown
that
high quality daycare
has
long-term effects and even
intergeneration
long-term effects and positive effects
and yeah positive okay so let me ask you
a couple of questions about that because
that's interesting in and of itself yes
do you think that
it has that daycare has particularly
positive effects
on the kids from mothers whose
maternal behavior is impaired so in head
start one of the hypothesis about why
head start the the the wide scale
anti-poverty initiative yeah in the u.s
one of the reasons that it had the
successful outcomes it did have which
were included um less high school
dropout and uh fewer teen pregnancies
and less arrests if i remember correctly
although no impact on cognitive
development part of the theory about why
that worked was that children in
particularly bad
families let's say or particularly
impaired families got out of those
families to some degree when they were
put in a different
uh maternal so to speak maternal setting
so
is it removal or is it something that's
being added and do you see the benefit
of daycare across the spectrum of
children or is it specific to the the
more at-risk kids
well the the best results long-term
results comes from jim mcmahon's
analysis
of
the data
for the second generation so it's clear
that
high quality it was the high scope
intervention that was done in michigan
shows
that
the children who
who were in this high quality daycare
compared to a control group
were
better off as they became adults
but also their own children
compared to the children of those who
did not go to the daycare
were much better off so what are the
elements that characterize high quality
daycare and at what ages and for how
long
yeah well they the
good quality
daycare
helps the children
learn
in terms of
interest social behavior of interacting
but also incur in terms of cognitive
development it's clear
i've been thinking recently looking at
the the impact of the
kovit 19
that we are going
to put a lot of money
on helping
helping old people
die later
there's the baby boomers are going to be
in the daycare home soon
and there's going to be a lot of people
in the daycare and what happened during
the epidemic
will sort of push us to put more
resources into helping old people
um in daycare centers
in in
in centers for yeah it's sort of
daycare centers for them right
but we have all these children that need
daycare
and
quality daycare is equivalent to the
school system
and it's amazing
that we are not providing free daycare
in the same way that we're providing
free
kindergarten and free elementary school
and free high school
children are at their best in terms of
learning
during the preschool years
and so we should be investing massively
into getting
all children
into high quality daycare
that will provide
they will be better prepared to benefit
from elementary school and from high
school and from university it's it's
really amazing that our societies
have not
pro are not providing
free
quality education from
essentially birth onwards
and and we know from
the research on cognitive development
that
the the years where our
brains are more open to
learning is
during the early years
um
so so let me ask you a couple of
questions about that i mean
there are
factors obviously that stand in the way
i mean i worked in the daycare business
for a while when i was very young and
developing standards for daycare in
alberta
the younger the children the higher the
ratio of teachers to children necessary
right so if you're if you have
two-year-olds in daycare you need
something approximating one teacher per
three
two-year-olds and so it becomes
expensive very rapidly if you want a
qualified uh teacher you need to spend
forty thousand dollars a year let's say
to have someone with university
education and divided by three that's
fifteen thousand and then you can double
that for the infrastructure so it's
about thirty thousand dollars per
child per year at that level for for
quality daycare and certainly that's so
much money that many people would not be
able to afford that if it was their
you know if they had especially if they
had a couple of kids and so do you
so
that's part of the reason it doesn't
happen i presume um
and then the question also arises is
whether
children who are coming from families
who are intact and
let's say psychologically healthy to the
degree that that's possible
is there an additional benefit for those
children to be placed in daycare or is
this something that's more specifically
appropriate for
for the children who are at risk for
that 17 let's say who who are
developmentally who are aggressive and
who also have
family structure that isn't optimal
yeah well
it's the the work by ekman is showing
that it's
the cost benefit analysis is
in favor of doing this for the children
who have
uh who need more support yeah well i
really i think i read recently that it's
350 000 a year to keep someone in prison
yeah uh
it's possible so it's extraordinarily
expensive in any case and maybe that
figure's wrong but your point is that
while there's deferred costs if those
early interventions don't occur and so
it's not a savings
yeah
so
i mean if you put together the home
visitation to
high-risk pregnant women and that i mean
pregnant women
they go and see
doctors they go
when they become pregnant and it's easy
to identify who needs help
and who doesn't need help so that's
so how would you identify how would you
identify them well the characteristics
that that we've
identified in in terms of uh
schooling
uh
physical and mental health problem uh
okay so a competent physician should be
able to determine that without
easy to to identify
and so if if you give them that
nurse
home visitation program
then
and
once the baby is born if you
if
the baby has access to daycare
um
and
access to daycare until
kindergarten
and then
we we did an experiment where we
provided
support to parents
of aggressive children aggressive
kindergarten children
this is
another
prevention experiment where we randomly
allocated
support to the parents
home visits to the parents
support to the teacher and social skills
training
with peers that are highly pro-social so
we created groups where you have the
most pro-social kids
and you put the least pro-social kids
one
in a small group
and they become friends with them the
pro-social
pro-social kids help the the less
pro-social kids
and we've shown that
it prevents
delinquency it prevents criminal
behavior in adulthood
so if you put these different
interventions together
from
essentially
the start of pregnancy up to
the end of elementary school
you will save a lot of money
you will help a lot of people
and prevent a lot of
misery in
in our
in our societies
you grouped pro-social children in
kindergarten
with antisocial children so more
pro-social children in the group
and i'd like to know two things
how did you formulate the groups like
how did you encourage the children to
to
initiate friendships within that group
and were you concerned at that point
that the pro-social kids would be
inclined towards more violence as a
consequence of being exposed to the
violent kids because i remember joan
mccord's work um and they seemed to
indicate the longitudinal study in um
in somerville massachusetts seemed to
indicate that grouping antisocial kids
together was a very bad idea that they
that made them so prisons for example
are a great place to make people even
more violent uh which is something that
should also be stressed it's not a wise
intervention to group anti-social people
together okay so you made these groups
how did you encourage the children to to
make friendships and and
yeah we we
did not
expect that that would happen uh what
what we did is
we put one um
i think it's one or
two i don't remember exactly in a group
of four or five
and the aim of the the
grouping was
to learn social skills
i mean it was sort of a class where you
learn
pro social skills like what what would
constitute something you could teach and
these were four-year-old kids basically
three or four no no they were in
elementary school oh so they're all oh
they're all they were so seven
oh okay okay so so so they have a bit
more sophistication at that point and
what sort of skills were they taught
well it's the usual social skill of how
you
get someone to enter a group how
you help others what you do when there's
this problem or that problem so it's
relatively
it's the social skills uh work that has
been done since the 1960s okay so do you
think it was the social skills training
or the friendships that developed that
socialized the kids yeah we we did not
our aim was not to that they would
become friends right right uh our aim
was that they would learn the social
skills and if if there are
good models uh then it's easier to to
learn
rather than having
a group of
non-pro-social skills trying to learn
together
it's that's very hard
it's only afterwards that we discovered
that
uh
two three years later
the the children who had problems who
participated in these groups
had more pro-social friends
two three years later it's not
necessarily which that's a long impact
yeah it's it's not necessarily
they were friends with the ones within
the group it's possible but
they
probably their behavior changed
and they were more acceptable
by the pro-social kids
uh than those who continued to aggress i
remember when we worked together that um
one of the
things i learned was that
the kids were aggressive at age two and
then most of them were socialized by the
age of four and if they weren't part of
what happened was that
it was difficult for the kids who
maintained their two-year-old level of
aggression at four or something
approximating it to make friends
and so then they got further isolated
and that seemed to be because so that
model is something like well your
parents are obviously a very important
source of socialization you've been
indicating that with mothers in
particular
but as children age and become more
socially sophisticated their peers
become an increasingly important source
of socialization and the reciprocity
that is necessary between peers is a
very important part of the socialization
of pro-social behavior
and so you're aggressive at four like
you were two none of the sophisticated
four-year-olds who play with you because
of that so you're alienated and isolated
and they continue to develop and you
stay where you were and maybe get also
angry and bitter and so forth as you're
excluded and is that is that still a
reasonable way of looking at it yeah
yeah that's exactly what appears to be
happening
um okay and so your intervention
perhaps
stop that from happening so so so
so
comprehensively
you got them back into the
play track and yes yeah okay so there's
another implication of your research i'd
like to
briefly discuss and and and then we'll
we'll continue with the main track
there's a tremendous
amount of
noise i would say in the popular culture
at the moment about the structure of
human social organizations critic
critiques of human social organizations
so we we tend to exist in hierarchies
that are oriented towards a particular
task or goal or around a
profession etc and and
the criticism is something like
hierarchies are tyrannical in their
central nature and they're predicated on
power and little else
and yet and if that was true what i
would expect to find as a consequence of
your research was that the proportion of
children who use aggression as a
strategy even initially when they're two
would be much higher like if power is
actually the force that moves you up
social hierarchies then the default
uh mode of interaction should be force
but
your research indicates that the force
the ability to use force is there in the
beginning but that
it isn't
overwhelmingly widely dispersed
and even more importantly as children
are socialized into these hierarchies
they become much less aggressive rather
than more and so to me that's a that's a
fatal blow to theories that posit that
sophisticated hierarchical organizations
are likely to be dominated by those
people who do nothing but
exercise power
and
i don't i'd like your opinion about
all of that or at least some of it
i guess it
depends on how you define power
um
the uh
well i would say i exert power on you
when i'm i'm compelling you to do
something you wouldn't do voluntarily
yeah yeah but
in in early childhood it's physical
aggression
and i i think that as we become more
sophisticated what we learn in early
childhood
is to talk
is to interact and convince people by
what you say
so it becomes
very verbal rather than
than physical well we learn to dance too
i mean one of the things you learn if
you're a successful child is how to take
turns
yes yes yeah
and and that's an unbelievably important
scaffold for
for well for conversation for example
but certainly for shared games and and
cooperative activity
yes yes and it's the children that can't
do that and that default to aggression
that don't do well yes
um
and
i i guess
there are so many things
that go wrong with those who
cannot adjust to to the group
that it's not one thing it's a number of
things
that
prevents them from
um
getting on
with others and getting the others to
accept them
in in their
group
and so they become rejected and the
rejected are the ones that aggress
uh
the others and and to some extent some
uh have pleasure in being rejected they
provoke others and and they're happy if
the others get mad and yeah well they
they'll look kids will default to
whatever strategy provides them with any
attention whatsoever yes and if they
can't do it in a sophisticated way
they're going to do it in an
unsophisticated way yes exactly
so and they can occupy that niche and
and get whatever um
attention is left over as a consequence
of that i mean i don't think there's
anything that a child finds more
intolerable than being absolutely
ignored
exactly
i agree
okay so um
how is your work being received broadly
and what i mean you won this award from
the uh um stop you won the stockholm
prize the 2000 oh it was saint augustine
by the way yes it was saint augustine so
yeah i uh
was looking for it
so you you won this 2017 stockholm prize
in criminology and the scandinavians
have done a tremendous amount of
long-term high-quality work on
criminology and aggression and all of
that so you're obviously receiving a
fair bit of attention from your peers
how has your work been received broadly
among sociologists and all of the other
members of disciplines that are that are
that have some focus on criminality and
aggression yes
well i you know i was surprised when i
uh
heard that i was getting the
the
stockholm prize
um
the stockholm prize is
given by an international it's sort of
the equivalent of it it's meant to be
the equivalent of the nobel prize for
for criminology
and i'm not a criminologist
i was trained as an educational
psychologist
and i was surprised that they gave me
this prize because
criminology has been
is i mean it's closer to sociology it's
it's uh
it's a social science more social than
psychology is
um right so it's concentrating on group
determinants of behavior economic
factors and yeah and and social factors
rather than intrinsic psychological
factors at the level of the individual
yes yes exactly
and so
the idea that we are
uh
we we are born good and it's the
environment that makes us bad
is is
more the way criminologists would look
at life
than the fact that we
we have we are born to survive in the
jungle and the environment makes us
adapt and adjust to a less violent
environment
i was i was surprised that
i was getting the the award because my
my work has been more
uh
psychological and to a certain extent
uh criticizing the the perspective that
we are uh
society um
is is not uh making us
bad
but um
but by and large making us better
yes
and
i guess that there is clearly in
criminology
people are recognizing more and more
um
the the psychological perspectives
of
human
development
and
there is clearly an openness to
the type of work that we have been doing
both in terms of the experimental work
it's very hard for people to
um
say the odd this is only words when you
do an experiment you have a control
group
and you show
the long-term effects
of of these
interventions well i also think it's
it's harder to um
what avoid
what the data
is indicating if the data results have
also come as a surprise to the
researcher i mean you said and i mean
that's been my experience constantly as
a research psychologist is that i find
out things that not only did i not
expect that i really didn't like yeah
and but those are much more compelling
and so you came in at this with a
russoian viewpoint essentially and but
what you saw convinced you that that
wasn't an appropriate uh
perceptual frame let's say
and and yeah so so it's good to see that
the criminologists have been open to
this and and what has been the
consequence of that and what do you
think the most trenchant remaining
criticisms of your approach and your
theorizing are like where are the
weaknesses in what you're doing as far
as you're concerned
well
i think the most important weakness is
not
not being able
to do
experiments that are still
that are much bigger
than
the experiments that that we have done
it's
it's hard to do
these
experiments did the randomized
controlled trials
i don't think there's any more difficult
psychological research endeavor than um
experimental
interventions yeah i mean the hurdles
are immense it's impossible to get
subjects
there's there's ethical concerns of a
multitude of sorts it's unbelievably
expensive it's time-consuming it's hard
it takes years before you generate data
to publish um there's a high probability
that your intervention is going to fail
you need an entire bureaucracy to run it
that has to be maintained over years
it's so difficult i'm amazed that anyone
ever does it yeah well i've
over the years i've
tried
many times
to convince
i i managed to convince one very rich
man
to support
and
to to support the work that we were
doing
and it's in is his environment
that convinced over time
uh may made so much trouble that we had
to drop it
to to drop this uh this switch surge not
because he didn't want it but he one
morning he said richard
i don't get the support from the people
around me and i can't go on with this
they are making my life too difficult
and so what kind of obstacles did he run
into as a consequence of supporting your
research well it was mainly the opinion
of the people around him
he's a billionaire
a lot of people want his money
and
he was
telling me let's go let's do it
um but after a while i said i'm getting
too much negative
uh
comments about about what you're doing
and and what what what look what what
are the objections is it is it focused
on the idea that the unpalatable idea
that there that there is a biology of
aggression let's say or that it's early
onset and innate in people or like i'm
very curious about this because i see
these sorts of hypothetically ethical
objections to scientific endeavor
popping up more and more frequently
everywhere and it doesn't surprise me
because the fact that we were ever able
to do genuine scientific research at all
is a complete bloody miracle i mean it's
only been around for 300 years and it's
only happened once so
we don't know the preconditions but what
what are the what are the obstacles that
he faced and
and you face let's say as a consequence
of your critics
well um
[Music]
the consequences
are that uh
for me are that
i think we have
the means
to advance knowledge so it's like
medicine
but
we don't have the support
from
um
the research
agencies
don't have enough money
to support these interventions so you
either get the money from someone who's
very rich
who wants to change the world
or you get support from
the ministry of education from the
ministry of health um
and
each time i've sort of
almost
got it and got the support
it
was taken away
for uh
political reasons um
and and the political reasons are what
what what's the objection what what is
it that's that's i mean we should also
point out that you were radically
successful at acquiring research funds
yes compared to other research
scientists and i mean that also is a
testament to your skill as an
administrator and and a communicator as
well as a researcher because it's very
rare that those three things come
together because they're all very
difficult so you've had success but
what's what's driving opposition and
also has that got worse in recent years
what's what's been your experience over
the last while well
over the last year with the pandemic we
appear to be having more success
there is the the quebec government
has
been putting in a lot of money uh
in research in terms of
helping
uh to
see what's what's coming
and
hopefully we will put in we will be able
to put in some
experiments
um
but
i i guess the the biggest
uh
handicap is that
governments and
i think it's like that everywhere
are not
really ready
to experiment
if you think of the
of
the education of children we should
constantly be experimenting imagine what
the faculties of education should have
been doing for the last 50 years yes and
they've done virtually none of it no
and that's my i guess my biggest
frustration
is
i can't believe we don't have
technologies to teach children to read
in six months by now
i mean yes yeah it's just it's it's
appalling
curious about the degree to which
you've run into philosophical opposition
because of the anti-russoian let's say
nature or
the partial anti-russoia nature of your
research because it does push against
the
the general consensus of the time
yeah
well
it from the
criminology and social that and the
social sciences in general
that was the the main criticism in the
sense that
the
social sciences are are more
based on a
russoin approach
uh to understanding who we are
um then the biological science and the
psychology from a
biological perspective
um
but i i guess uh part part of that as as
you know well is a personality
of the people who who go into different
fields
we go into a field where we feel at ease
with the way the majority are thinking
and it's very hard to to change the way
people think
and i guess well that's why we need
science and research and experiments
because we're so hard to
teach that we need the data to be and to
be hit over the head with it repeatedly
before we can alter our presuppositions
yeah
but
what you said earlier in our
conversation is that it
it's
it's relatively rare that you find
something that is
sort of opposite to what you think
and you accept it and you say ah
i i had not thought things were like
that no you have to train graduate
students for like five years before they
can do that yeah before they get
convinced that that's when you've
actually actually know you've discovered
something this is surprising i'd rather
it would go away but i can't make it go
away despite my wishes maybe it's true
yeah
but
it's so satisfying when you sort of look
back and you say i was going that way
and look when i i'm
completely the opposite of where i i
thought i should be going
and
people need to understand that that is
satisfying it's satisfying to say
i was wrong
that that that's crazy what that
the way
you i was looking at things is the wrong
way and
so i think that's that's what science
provides if if you're
doing science not
to
confirm what you think but doing science
learn
new things and and understand things
that you did not understand before
well one of the things that that that
shaped the way i think i guess there
were two things one was the
realization and that was partly as a
consequence of of
of being exposed to joan mccord's work
in
in somerville because that was a early
intervention program for anti-social
behavior and other at-risk behaviors
that made things worse
much to her surprise her her
continual personal surprise i mean that
shaped the entirety of her career that
because
they did a broad-scale intervention with
at-risk kids and yet the outcome showed
that the experimental group did worse on
almost every outcome measure and the
conclusion was that
they sent the kids out of the city to
summer camp together
and that seemed to be a fatal error
essentially grouping them together made
them much more
prone to aggression but also all sorts
of mental illnesses and so i it was
evident whenever you talked to dr mccord
how shocked she was that that had
occurred and she she spent a lot of her
uh time after that telling social
scientists look
don't
be so sure that your stupid intervention
is going to produce the results that you
wish it would the world is a lot more
complicated than that and so
once you start to understand that
your a priory axiom
might do a tremendous amount of damage
if it is allowed untrammeled access to
the broader culture it tends to make you
much more conservative as a research
designer and thinker
and and that should
you know it's very difficult and scary
to have one of your axioms violated
because you have to do a lot of re
consideration but it's also very
frightening to know that you could be an
agent of catastrophe despite your
well-meaning efforts and that's actually
the most likely outcome when you do a
social science intervention because it's
very hard to make things better and it's
really easy to make them worse
so you also showed that you've also
delved into the biology of this and the
and in a variety of interesting ways
there's the basic biology and so
maybe we could talk a little bit about
the biology of aggressive behavior and
its dysregulation
so i'll start that off and and
i've i've been very attracted by the uh
behavioral neuroscientists pancep and
jeffrey gray jackpanx and jeffrey gray
particularly and they've basically shown
that we have modules
neuropsychological models modules
neurophysiological modules for our basic
emotions and motivations and fear and
surprise and
disgust and
play for that matter hunger sex drive
defensive aggression um
predatory aggression which i think is
more what you're studying is the
aggression in the service of an aim
rather than defensive aggression um
and so
these modules
are there right from the beginning they
manifest themselves in individually
different ways and then they're brought
under control or integrated as people
develop what do you see as key to the
biological understanding of the kinds of
of aggression itself but also of the
kinds of differences in aggression that
you're studying
um
i i must admit that i have not
been focused on the biological
dimensions
except except the
once i understood about epigenetics
i sort of
turned to
look at the the the importance of
epigenetics
and so you were interested in the
intergenerational
transmission or of aggressive behavior
and is that what led you into and we
should also define epigenetics let
everybody know what what that signifies
and what you were exploring yeah
um well
i guess it was um
around 2004. i i i was part of a um
the canadian institute of advanced
research that fraser mustard had created
where we were committee on human
development
and
um
one of our guests
was moishi schiff
from mcgill university a biologist who
was
working on epigenetics with
with michael
at mcgill university
and moishi uh we were there was a group
of geneticists
uh
that group of geneticists
was
working on
human
development
and so moishi came and showed us
the mechanism the epigenetic mechanisms
of modern
that
rats that are well
licked at birth
their brains are changed they're
it
has an impact on gene expression
and they live well if they're licked
they're cared for it's really important
it's not a trivial behavior it's it's
the focus of maternal love and
competence in rats so i mean people
often don't understand how relevant
animal research can be and this is
who studies licking in rats it's like no
no you don't understand this is a key
component of
social interaction and protection and it
signifies the existence of a relatively
benevolent environment
exactly
yeah
and and so
these rats were living longer
so licking
had the long-term impact on on the lives
of
these pops and
i remember that was 2004 and
most of the geneticists
around
the the table were saying ah this is
incredible
and they were sort of
not
really accepting
that
the explanation that that moishe was
was giving
of a
facilitating
gene expression and
influencing brain development yeah so so
let's stop there and take that apartment
because this is quite remarkable so
look one of the things that can happen
when you're exposed to a new environment
is that you can acquire new information
and you learn but another thing that can
happen is the environment can turn on
one set of genes
that are relevant to neural development
or another set and so it's as if in some
sense that your genes contain a
tremendous amount of not expressed
potential and then you enter an
environment and that set of potentials
relevant to that environment turns on
and it's the and it's reminiscent to me
of the platonic theory that all
knowledge is remembering in some sense
is that we have this massive store of
potential
residing inside our biological apparatus
coded at the genetic level but that's
not necessarily turned on because of the
or because of the environments that we
inhabit or don't inhabit okay so you put
rats in a benevolent environment rat
pups in a benevolent environment and
that turns on a certain set of
uh genetic codes that alters well things
as fundamental as their lifespan
and so what's the epi in epigenetics
there is it's it's the environmental
impact on the genetic structure yes and
sometimes that can be transmissible
which is also revolutionary yes yes yeah
and it's been shown with uh with humans
so um
the uh i
invited moishi uh to work with us and so
we we've been
doing um
we've been doing epigenetic studies uh
of the children
that
that we
we are following and we've been showing
that the children
who
are sort of chronic aggressives
um
have
we see differences in in
epigenetic
expression
um
so we've done that with a small sample
of boys in in our samples and um
the results have been confirmed in a
larger longitudinal study in uh
in great britain
um
where
they've shown that
the quality of muttering is
impacting
gene expression in early childhood and
has long-term consequences on
behavior during early adulthood now in
this this paper that was published in
nature it's an it's an interview with
you it talks about suomi's research
research yeah dna difference in dna
methylation patterns between nurtured
monkeys
and
those separated from their mothers yes
and and
sumi's suomi's research indicates that
um postnatal of adversity so that the
maternal disruption in the maternal bond
affects more than 4 000 genes what is
one-fifth of the genome and that it
tends to cluster in certain chromosomal
regions
and also that it alters expression of a
gene that somi's group had linked to the
function of of serotonin which is a like
it's like the conductor of the entire
neurological symphony a very very
crucially important um neural
transmitter and so
you you also
that you you ran a parallel research
pathway with suomi as well and was that
related to the one that you did that
yeah
yeah yeah sumi was part of the committee
of the
cihr
committee where where moishi came to uh
give us a talk and we decided because
steve sumi's work
uh has been they were separating
the babies from their mothers at birth
um right so it's a very dramatic
intervention yeah that that was it has
has been done
um it's harlow that started this work
and then i guess the 19 late 1950s
earlier right he studied the famous
studies with the cloth covered wire uh
pseudo mothers and the wire mothers yeah
so so it was all about the attachment of
the child to to the mother so the the
brains of these
monkeys had been saved
and
so
steve sumi said well let's look at the
epigenetic
differences for these monkeys that were
separated at birth and those who weren't
separated so it's it's it's a wonderful
way of showing that separation from your
mother
at birth
has behavioral consequences but it also
has important
consequences on gene expression in your
brain
right so it's even in some sense it's
even more fundamentally important and so
do you do you think
do you think that the the disruption of
the mother
child
relationship that you see in the
families that fail to inhibit the
expression of aggression do you think
that that's akin to maternal deprivation
it's it's just a lesser
i mean you can imagine a continuum of of
maternal care with absolute separation
at one end and perfect bonding at the
other there's going to be a continuum
and
more impaired mothers have have a less
um
the the the disruption in the behavior
is akin to partials
to partial separation from the mother
it's something like that i mean
psycho psychoanalysts psychologists have
always made much of the necessity of the
eric erickson for example as well of the
absolute necessity of that initial bond
and yeah and that's associated with
well with really basic behaviors touch
play like fundamental behaviors and you
see for example studies showing that
i remember these studies
of mothers breastfeeding
depressed and non-depressed mothers
breastfeeding and the videos were sped
up and
you could see the non-depressed mothers
and the baby who was breastfeeding in
this kind of dance where one would move
and then the other would move in the uh
and then the mother would move and
there's this synchrony and reciprocity
already emerging in the course of
breastfeeding that was disrupted among
the depressed
mothers and their children and and so
you can trace the development of that
reciprocity back way way to the
beginning and i think you know i think
it definitely manifests itself in in the
highly social structuring of such things
such primordial things as feeding
might also be a reason why it's the
mother's behavior that's so crucial in
the in the early stages because she's so
integrally involved in that early
reciprocity
yes
and so that's after birth but you can
imagine that
even during pregnancy
you have these different effects
on
what the mother is living is affecting
the development of the brain of the
child in neutral yeah well you wonder if
like if the postnatal environment is
harsher let's say and less welcoming are
the epigenetic transformations uh
producing preparation for
existence in a much more hobbesian world
yes well that's one that's one
hypothesis
that that you
your brain is prepared to
survive in a very tough world
compared to others who who had a
uh
more
gentle environment during pregnancy
right so the assumption would be that
in some sense the assumption that your
biology is making is that
perhaps the reason the mother's behavior
is
altered
in in a negative way is because she is
genuinely in a negative environment that
is a harsher environment and so
aggression perhaps in a harsher
environment
is
associated with a higher probability of
of of um
survival but you but you you did
indicate
we talked about this just a trifle
you don't have evidence suggesting
though that the more aggressive kids are
doing better in their
group of
of rejected children let's say
because i always wonder is there a
parallel hierarchy there's obviously a
hierarchy in prison
yes and so what if if you look at men in
prison
what is it that the men who are doing
better
are doing are they the more violent
criminals are they the more
aggressive people or is it even in
prisons does reciprocity
i mean obviously if you have a gang
loyalty is still rewarded and you're
going to be looked on very badly if you
um
don't maintain the integrity of your
gang there's a certain risk that's
that's what that's the socialized
violent
uh pattern
as opposed to the just chaotic violent
pattern
do you think it's a developmental
mechanism gone astray that the
epigenetic transformation constitutes or
is it is it a parallel form of
adaptation
well i
i don't know
um
it's
there's
all these very nice things that
need to be studied and
and understood
um
so it's for for those who are interested
in psychology there's a lot of
interesting research
that needs to be done in the future
and so
let let's maybe we can we can close this
off with a bit of discussion about um
the career of a psychological researcher
it's it's not something that people know
a lot about i mean what's what
how would you evaluate your career it's
been
has it been what you wanted it to be and
why what what what's been compelling and
interesting about it yeah
and who should consider such a thing
such a career
well you know uh people ask me uh if if
i'm
still working uh
if i'm retired and my answer is
i cannot retire i've never worked
it's
i think my whole when i look at my whole
career i've had fun
doing what i i i was doing
and i would never have imagined doing
what i did
from
year to year i
could not have predicted what
what was coming
i started my career um
in in prisons uh working with with
prisoners
and over time
i i
then work with juvenile delinquents and
then i went to work
with
preschool children and
when you say worked what did you what do
you mean what were you doing at that
time
um
with
i i work with mentally ill offenders i
was uh
a psychologist who who was
trying to treat these people clinical
you're working as a clinical
psychologist well yeah counselor i was
an educational psychologist in
in
a unit
of
mental mentally ill offenders and then i
worked with juvenile delinquents
and eventually i went to do my phd and
did my phd on the treatment of
uh
juvenile delinquents
and it's over time i sort of went
further and further in terms of i
started research on kindergarten
children and following them over time
and what do you think tilted you richard
what do you think tilted you
in the research direction
i mean you were practicing as a
counselor essentially and i assume that
you found that engaging and and
meaningful although i might be wrong
maybe you were looking for something
else but there was something in the
research domain that that attracted your
attention and your interest what do you
think it was
um
i i
the first research i did was
uh at the bachelor level
in physical education i did a bachelor
in physical education
and
i simply
loved doing
the research i was doing on the
flexibility in yoga
but the pleasure
of
doing something where you control and
and you check and
and you're not sure
and you finally get data and you analyze
the data
um you know it's like i remember there's
a rush in data analysis that's like like
pulling the the the handle on a slot
machine you know you put all these
months of effort into setting up these
experiments and then you do an analysis
and you wait you know in 30 seconds
you're going to find out whether this
was a complete bloody catastrophic waste
of time or whether you've actually hit
gold
there's something
you know i mean i found statistics
pretty dry when i was looking at other
people's data or when i was you know
going through the mechanics of learning
it but once it was being applied to data
sets i had generated i couldn't get
enough of the analytic tools and there
is a real i mean i love doing counseling
and clinical work but there was
something really engaging and compelling
about the research
yeah
and i find that
planning the research is
is interesting i i love
writing
grant proposals
because
in right in writing and proposing trying
to convince others
to give you money to do something you
have
to review the literature very well and
you sort of understand
you you start
understanding
uh this idea that you have in your head
much better
so
the whole process of
thinking about a problem submitting a
proposal doing the
collection of data analyzing the data
and writing up the papers
these are all different things
that are extremely
interesting to do in themselves
and putting all that together um
i mean
40 years has gone like this
because you're sort of immersed into
this
this work and
there's something wonderful about having
the opportunity to really devote time to
specifying and unpacking a complex
problem yeah it's something i really
loved
i loved doing collectively too with the
people like you that i had the pleasure
to work with across time you know we
could we could focus on a problem that
was philosophically compelling
i mean when we started this discussion
with like well are are human beings
innately aggressive or does society make
them that way well you know that's a
major philosophical problem it's like
okay well we can and then you sit down
with your colleagues and you generate a
bunch of ideas about
like a whole plethora of hypotheses
about what might be the case and what
not and that's fun too because that
blows you out of your ideological
presuppositions if you have a good group
of people and you make much more
detailed you generate much more detailed
ideas and so that hypothesis generating
part of the process which is not well
specified and almost never talked about
methodologically that's really exciting
so you get people together they've all
read it was one of the things that was
so fun about working with you and bob is
that you both had encyclopedic knowledge
of literatures that weren't overlapping
and so and and i brought my own
knowledge to bear on the subject and the
the the interactions between
us and well many other people that we
both worked with
expands the whole universe of
conceptualization at the hypothesis
level and then you have the ability to
find out if you're actually wrong which
is such a privilege because that's the
problem with philosophy in some senses
you can never be shown to be wrong
whereas science will show you and then
you can do something that's maybe a bit
better as a consequence
so yes yeah exactly it is a ridiculously
exciting endeavor despite the despite
the obstacles and the difficulty in
getting published and so forth but
that's all built into it too that in a
way that's necessary
so
and you do have the the the
possibility of producing some permanent
alteration in human knowledge you know i
think that it
it definitely seems to me that
the research that you've done is of
broad philosophical interest it's like
well look first of all most people
aren't that aggressive right from the
beginning so aggression
it's certainly not the expression of
aggression that we're primarily selected
for however there is a subset
and and they and it tends to be pretty
stable in that subset and but those are
people who have generally suffered
impairments in their primary
relationships fundamental impairments in
their primary relationships so it's
actually a deviation from the human norm
although an important one rather than
something that's central to the optimal
pathway of human development and then
you have the the uh exquisite pleasure
of perhaps addressing that and learning
from your
uh your attempts to address in a way
that also pulls you in some sense out of
the political
right because it becomes so pragmatic
and so practical although also still
philosophically interesting
you you you can you can specify it at a
level of detail that makes the political
irrelevant
and that's actually when you know you've
specified it at the right level of
detail it's like well no your your
ideology isn't going to provide an
answer here it might provide a
hypothesis but that's all
and so
and it's also extremely uh entertaining
to
mentor people along that developmental
pathway and to watch them learn to think
and and
it's a very complicated and and
all-consuming process that research that
of being a research scientist
so so is there anything is there
anything that we missed that's really
relevant oh yes there is
i wanted to ask you about sex
differences in aggression
so there's a
the
the physical aggression tends to be more
common among males okay so what you've
studied boys and girls we need to talk
about the girls so to let
i'm opening the floor tell let's let's
talk about girls aggression
well uh
girls
are
used more in direct aggression
than physical aggression
compared to
to boys
and
i mean it makes it makes sense and
from a biological perspective from a
physical perspective girls are are less
able to to win
a physical fight
than
boys
so so there is this indirect uh
aggression
and
i guess similarly to boys the girls who
are
more aggressive compared to the other
girls
and more hyperactive so there is
aggression and hyperactivity
those are the girls that have
in the long run
the
more
problems
they
aggressive aggressive in the sense of in
dark indirect aggression yeah can you
take that apart a bit what what what
kind of you have markers for physical
aggression hitting kicking biting
stealing what are the markers for india
okay the markers for
um
it's uh it's talking
to some
talking about someone
and telling how bad that person is
you know it's
the the
indirect aggression of uh
is more
doing things behind the back of others
yes so it's sub subversive reputation
destruction yeah
essentially that's that's which seems to
scale quite well in online environments
yeah
i guess so
um
so
girls who are
more
in direct aggression
prone
and are at the same time hyperactive are
the ones
who
will have
much more problems
in life
and are likely to be the mothers who are
the
ones who will be less successful uh with
their children right so it's so there's
no evidence that it's a good strategy
it doesn't seem to be producing a
desirable outcome
no
i i suspect that um
[Music]
and in saying this i realize that we
haven't looked at that
that
the
intelligence must play a role in this
in the sense that
the more intelligent
they are
probably the more successful they are
but but the girls in general the girls
who have
in
uh childhood
are hyperactive
and are also
tend to
aggress others
from an indirect way and how how early
can you see that because it requires a
certain degree of verbal ability or or
do you see young girls like dragging one
playmate away from another to to as a
form of indirect aggression say that
would be more behavioral measure how
early can you detect that well we we've
done it from kindergarten
um and it's
it's based on
uh it's based on report teacher reports
um and i guess we've done it also in
in day care
but
the long term data that we have comes
from
teacher reports on these behaviors so we
should do a little sideways move there
too
you know
there are various ways you can
derive data direct observation
you can get peer reports of children
talking about their peers you can get
reports from parents mothers or fathers
or mothers and fathers and you can get
teacher reports and my re my memory is
that
of those of that category forget direct
observation for a minute the teacher
reports tend to be reasonably accurate
because teachers are familiar with a
wide range of children's behavior so
they are somewhat better at comparing
children whereas parents have a much
narrower exposure is that is that still
out yes yes exactly
and
i mean it's it's an important
uh finding that
kindergarten teachers
can identify
both boys and girls who will have
long-term problems
right so we we need to rely
on what the kindergarten teachers are
telling us about the behavior of the
children
because those behaviors are good
predictors
of having problems in the long run and
so we need to do
interventions
early at the end of
kindergarten and in first grade
that are based on these
teacher reports
the teachers are really very reliable
in terms of identifying early early
early diagnosis so so to speak yes of
long-term problems richard are they
girls who are more likely to use
indirect aggression
are they specifically the mothers who
are most likely to give rise to
aggressive boys or or is it is it more
general um what lack of optimal function
something like that
or how specific it is is it to the
proclivity for aggression
well um
we
we have
data
up to age 40
in terms of how successful
these
children
became as adults
and the teacher reports
of
these behaviors hyperactivity and
aggression
are very good
predictors
of how much money
people will
have in terms of
of win on the job market
uh when they are in their 40s right so
that's hierarchical position in the
socioeconomic pyramid essentially yeah
and do you remember the effect sizes
just out of curiosity what what kind of
correlations are you managing to produce
between the teacher reports of
kindergarten behavior and and outcomes
at 40.
um i i cannot
remember
that well the fact that they're
significant at all is
dead relevant because that's a that's a
huge gap in time yeah and i mean the
only thing i can think of that would be
that stable perhaps would be
the incidence of aggressive behavior
because it tends to be really stable but
also general cognitive ability because
it tends to be extremely stable as well
so
hyperactivity
uh impulsivity aggression
in kindergarten those who are
really
not in
relatively good control are at high risk
of failing in school
and
failing for for the rest of their lives
and this tells us that we can
we can rely on teacher reports
and we should use that
to give services
to children early on
and our experimental work has shown that
that if if you rely on these
assessment
and you give
support to these high-risk children
in early elementary school it will
change their lives and it's not being
done systematically enough
we we sort of wait wait wait interesting
you know because i talked to bjorn
lomberg a while back and he's put
together multiple teams of economists to
rank order
world problems serious world problems by
the potential return on investment in
spending money to solve them
and
frequently what comes up at the top of
the lists are interventions in early
childhood to increase early childhood
health health particularly uh nutrition
etc it's a it's a
there are roi's return on investments
like 250 to one it's remarkable but
you're saying something quite similar
which is you know this is this is an
intelligent
pla and it would be so nice to see
public policy increasingly informed by
a combination in some sense of science
and economics right and and you could
also see that that could produce at
least in some cases
consensus across ideological barriers
it's like well really you if you're
conservative you really want more
criminal adolescents and young males
probably not you know anything to reduce
violent criminality seems to be a plus
if you're on the left side of the
spectrum you think well those are
disenfranchised people uh mothers and
and and those families and so devoting
resources to the amelioration of that
problem seems to be ethically demanded
not just justified and so
well hopefully
that's the purpose of public education
right is that we can make this
information as broadly known as possible
that and so maybe i'll sum it up a bit
and you can add anything you want and so
your research has indicated that um
aggression which especially physical
aggression hitting kicking biting
stealing
is not precisely species typical
behavior because most children young
children don't engage in that except
sporadically there is a population that
does it more uh
regularly and predictably with greater
frequency
they tend to come from disturbed
maternal environments um there are
interventions that can ameliorate that
they're cost effective from a return on
investment point of view and they have
broad positive effects
the effects of the
um sub-optimal maternal environments are
uh
are
what would you call it they're
wide-ranging
you see
the detrimental effects of a disturbed
maternal environment across a wide range
of behaviors including propensity to
violence there's a multi-generational
proclivity and
that's all accompanied by biological
changes that are quite profound and that
also may have multi-generational
consequences
that and then i'd add to that the gender
difference
that that there are patterns of
aggression that characterize males more
particularly although some females and
and patterns that characterize females
although also some males
and the ones and the and it also seems
to be easier to
ameliorate the
uh tendency towards aggression in girls
than it does in boys
that's that seems to be about
that seems to be a reasonable coverage
of cover of what we've what we've talked
about anything that you want to add to
that or that you think people should
know that we haven't talked about that
you know about yeah well i think we've
covered
most of it
i
there's nothing that
i can think of that we've missed
although we probably missed a few things
but i can no doubt can't think about it
no doubt
well thank you very much for talking to
me today and and for walking through
this i hope people i presume i expect
that people will find it extremely
interesting and illuminating and
surprising and practically useful and
also i would say hopefully inspiring you
know it's it's so nice to hear you talk
about what you've discovered and why
it's relevant but also that
engaging in the process of learning all
of this has been
um deeply meaningful philosophically and
practically and that
that you can speak of excitement with
your
re about your research career and about
the people that you've mentored and the
entire process ranging across all of the
elements of the scientific process and
that you view that in retrospect as well
you're still doing it first of all
because you love it and in retrospect
you think it was a wonderful way to
spend your life
and so hooray for all of that and you
know you despite this is something
that's very positive too is despite the
counter cultural
um
what would you say
results
of your research
you've actually been remarkably
successful at gaining research money
on a compare
on a comparative basis and of publishing
and like you could get this out there
the scientific endeavor is robust enough
so that
even findings that don't run in the
direction that people might like
do tend to be generated and
and published and discussed and have an
impact over time
no reason for cynicism or undue cynicism
yeah i agree i agree the
the world is
open to uh
new ideas and and
change
it just takes time and it's a pity that
we we don't have a few
centuries to live we have to
sort of
count on the next generation
to continue the work and from my
perspective we've had so many
great students
that are
doing um
[Music]
exceptional work
and
the future to me looks very bright in
terms of the advancement of of
the science of human behavior
we've come from a long way
there's a long tradition
behind us
but
there's an exciting future
um i hope i'll continue to see part of
it
and you've been
jordan you've
played
an important role in
in in this
path towards
convincing people that
research
is
an important uh
very important
way of ameliorating
the life of humans
so let's let's close with one practical
issue if you were
going to recommend to a young person
what they should study
to prepare to be a researcher a
psychological researcher a clinical
psychological researcher of of your type
what what's what should what should they
do at the bachelor's level let's say
what what's the right preparation and
then let's walk through the process
bachelor masters phd postdoc because
people don't know that and so
what what do you look for in a student
at the ba if you're looking for a
master's level student what should have
they done in their bachelor's degree
um
unfortunately we are not
we are not working with the
students at the bachelor's
at the bachelor level
um
[Music]
probably because i haven't been teaching
for
for the past
25 years and so i'm not in contact with
uh
with bachelor level students but from
what i can
i can say from my own experience and
interacting with some of the
younger students
it's
i guess they have to be passionate
and at the same time ready to work very
hard
to um
clarify
uh
how you go about
understanding
um
what you want to to understand
uh so
you need it's it's both of those you
need the interest and the discipline uh
i guess it's it's like that in every
discipline even a hockey player or a
football player it is if you want to be
successful yeah right you need to be
interested because you have to want to
yeah and at the same time
you have to take the time and
and
like
investing yourself
thanks again richard i it's much
appreciated and it's really good to see
you again and to talk to you it's been
far too long it's i don't think we've
seen each other for
20 years maybe it's all at least at
least yeah yes
you were a very young man then yes yes
yes it was it was back in the late 90s i
think like
that was the last time i spent time with
you in montreal
so yeah it's a long time ago
so well i learned a tremendous amount
working with you and from your research
and and it's been extremely um
engaging and useful and i hope everyone
who's listening has found this useful
and
and and interesting so
thanks again you haven't lost your
passion
no
no no no
no it's still there so thank god for
that
great well keep it jordan it's a
wonderful passion
[Music]
you